enemy is one of the most confusing films
I have ever seen upon first viewing I
had a definite grasp on the central
story I was easily able to decipher its
hidden messages
it was the added elements of spiders
keys and surreal imagery that had me
boggled it's now been over two months
since I initially viewed the film and I
feel at this point I've come to an
accurate knowledge of its meanings so as
I've done in the past let's get nerdy
about enemy and talk in depth about its
deep-rooted symbolism and metaphors as a
warning this review contains heavy
spoilers so you haven't seen the film
yet
I'd suggest watching my spoiler free
review beforehand when I analyze only
God forgives I mentioned that certain
elements of that film were open to
interpretation I'd like to start this
review out by stating effect there is
without a doubt correct and incorrect
interpretations of enemy I've read many
attempts at analyzing this film and some
have proved wildly inaccurate no spiders
are not taking over the world as some
have stated no Jake Gyllenhaal does not
have an identical twin as some have
believed they are in fact the same
person I'll back up all of these
comments with statements from the
filmmakers as well as my own personal
interpretation let's start with a quote
from Denis the director himself
basically I think that this movie is a
documentary about my subconscious or at
the commentary about Jake Gyllenhaal
subconscious I think that the best way
to describe it would be it's a danaka
movie on acid or or a documentary about
Jake Gyllenhaal subconscious it's a man
we decide to to leave his leave his
mistress to go back to his pregnant wife
and we see the story from his
subconscious point of view from the
mouths of the man who made the film this
is a battle that's raging inside Jake's
mind but what could lead him to wage
such a disturbing subconscious war with
him
self and what the hell are those spiders
all about there are two versions of Jake
in this film history teacher Jake and
actor Jake
to avoid confusion this is how I will
refer to them it's easy to tell the
difference between the two history
teacher Jake is neurotic and messy his
appearance always unkempt actor Jake
wears expensive clothing his hair always
looks good and he wears a wedding ring
the film opens with a voiceover from
Jake's mother she sounds concerned about
the condition of his new apartment it's
clear she sang this on a voicemail we
then get an insert of Sara Gavin's
character nude and pregnant then the
words chaos is order yet undeciphered
appear on screen a quote from the book
which this film is based we immediately
see actor Jake holding a key entering a
seedy sex club of some sort as men stand
in silence watching women masturbate and
other such things actor Jake watches a
woman present a large spider on a
platter and she moves her high heel
slowly above it about to squash it next
we see history teacher Jake his first
words in his lecture to his class are
control it's all about control he then
begins to discuss dictatorships and how
they censor any means of individual
expression and then he says and it's
important to remember this that this is
a pattern that repeats itself throughout
history this repeating pattern is
mentioned quite often in the movie later
on history teacher Jake says it was
Hegel and said that all the great
greatest world events happened twice and
then Karl Marx added the first time it
was a tragedy the second time to farce
continuing in the vein of spider imagery
the wires above Toronto appear like a
spiderweb he walks home and passes a
mural of a man giving a Roman fascist
symbol defiance against rule
dictatorships and fear of commitment are
all themes that enemy has a woven
through it sometimes it's clear through
dialogue other times
imagery the next few scenes make it
clear that his life is immensely
repetitious he gives lectures that just
come off as memorized he has sex with
his girlfriend played by Melanie Laurent
his apartment is literally empty all he
seems to have is a bed and a computer
soon a co-worker recommends a film to
him seemingly out of the blue without
any real build-up to this conversation
history teacher Jake decides to write
this film at a local video store take
note of the song playing in the store
it's called the cheater it's lyrics
telling the story of a man who has no
business being with women because he
can't control his urges to sleep around
after watching the film and then
attempting to force himself on his
unwilling girlfriend he dreams about the
film he just saw in the recesses of his
mind he sees someone who looks exactly
like him in the film he wakes and skims
through the movie finding the shot it's
very clear that the actor portraying the
bellboy looked just like him and he
becomes obsessed with meeting this man
he compares a noticeably torn photo of
himself to the actor probably a post
breakup photo with the woman he took the
photo with torn out
he begins doing research about the actor
finding the other films he had a pardon
when he goes to rent the other films
take note of the poster attack of the
50-foot woman this leads him to the
talent agency of actor Jake where he has
a conversation with the security guard
who recognizes him saying you haven't
been around here for ages yeah I don't
know how long it's been six months out
sit six months or more he's given a
package meant to go to actor Jake which
allows him to find his address and phone
number when he tries to call the woman
on the other line recognizes his voice
thinking that history teacher Jake is
really actor Jake playing a joke after a
series of awkward calls history teacher
Jake finally reaches actor Jake and
tries to convince him that they need to
meet it's now that we meet actor Jake
and we see what his life is like he's
healthy he wears nice clothes he loves
blueberries and his wife is unfairly
suspicious of him
questioning him about the phone call
that he just had an accusing him of
lying to her when she asks are you
seeing her again he explodes at her
saying it was a man it's clear that
actor Jake although cleaner and more
well-off is dealing with fear of
commitment and also feels as if his
freedom has been removed by his pregnant
wife it's also clear that he has been
unfaithful in the past since she used
the word again as if it has happened
before this would explain why in the
opening scene he was visiting a sex club
he is afraid of the responsibility of
starting a family and being in a
committed relationship this is extremely
important to understanding the meaning
of the film including the spiders next
history teacher Jake and actor Jake
agreed to meet at a hotel they both feel
the need to see each other as if they
have some uncommon connection after
Jake's wife soon appears at history
teacher Jake's school and her look upon
seeing him as one of extreme sadness and
pain then history teacher Jake asks her
a question which reveals even more how
many months are you six that's nice I
find it very interesting that actor Jake
hasn't been to his talent agency in six
months and his wife is also six months
pregnant this adds to the idea of actor
Jake having extreme commitment issues
most likely brought on by fear of being
controlled or dictated by a woman and
child when history teacher Jake gets up
she attempts to call him and the
filmmaker makes it very obvious that
actor Jake answers after he disappears
from frame leaving the possibility that
they are the same person out there this
is clearly not a fantasy or delusion
going on inside the mind of his wife but
it is a psychological disorder of sorts
for the two Jakes later when she's home
actor Jake returns supposedly from a run
complaining that they are out of his
favorite organic blueberries she lays on
the couch sad and afraid saying how the
man she saw at the school
looked exactly like him what's happening
she says and when he says he doesn't
know what she's talking about she
replies I think you know I feel that she
is slowly discovering that her husband's
mind has split she wants him to come to
terms with it and accept this fact which
is why she appears so emotionally
bothered by it I mean logically if you
found out that your spouse had someone
out there who looked identical would you
be so emotional about it crying and
everything it would be weird for sure
but it's clear to me what she's really
concerned about is that they are
literally the same person and she's hurt
and scared by the fact that she's driven
him to this state this is when we get
our next spider vision a woman with a
spider head passes by him as he walks he
has this dream after his wife is
questioning him about his real motives
and tries to get him to explain
everything to her history teacher Jake
is now walking down the hall of the
hotel he's agreed to meet actor Jake in
we see two shots of a sexually dressed
woman walking past him similar to how
the woman with the spider had passed him
in his dream next the two meet comparing
themselves noticing they both have an
identical scar history teacher Jake gets
spooked and leaves but not before giving
actor Jake the package the talent agency
gave him the next two shots focus on the
characters dealing with the stress of
this situation and eventually after Jake
begins to follow history teacher Jake
noticing Melanie Lorant and following
her as well
how would actor Jake know exactly where
to find history teacher Jake these
questions are necessary since the large
majority of this film takes place in the
subconscious of the lead characters mind
as he battles to accept his actual
reality while on the train actor Jake
has a moment in which he GOx that
Melanie from head to toe but he quickly
turns around trying to deal with the
temptation as a man he has obvious
issues with being faithful this scene
ends with one shot of actor Jake relaxed
in his chair
appearing in deep thought his wife
asleep next to him did this entire scene
take place in his mind was he roaming
the recesses of his mind trying to learn
about this other version of himself
next history teacher Jake visits his
mother explaining the situation to her
it's clear it's history teacher Jake
since he's not wearing his wedding ring
his mother says the last thing you need
used to be meeting strange man in the
tones you have enough trouble sticking
with one woman don't you this adds to my
earlier assumption that jake has been
unfaithful in the past his mother offers
him some blueberries but he says he
doesn't like them of course you do she
says it's clear that history teacher
Jake is repressing memories of his
actual self attempting to escape the
person he is due to fear of commitment
and the desire to be unfaithful she says
he has a nice apartment a respectable
job and that he should quit his fantasy
of being an actor now there's a lot of
interesting things there the movie opens
with her saying in a voicemail that she
doesn't like his apartment but now she's
saying it's nice she's saying he has a
respectable job since she says he has a
respectable job but that he should quit
his acting fantasy this leads me to
believe his acting job has gone nowhere
those three films he was in led to
nothing so that would mean he's actually
a history teacher right this would lead
me to believe that earlier when his wife
says she went to his work that she was
in fact starting to realize the
magnitude of her husband's psychosis and
was desperately trying to connect with
him to try and help by going along with
his illness acting like she didn't know
that he is a teacher in real life after
this scene we see a giant spider roaming
Toronto this has also left many
perplexed what does this huge creature
signify I will explain this at the end
when I get in depth about the spiders
soon actor Jake is practicing something
he will say to history teacher Jake
asking himself in the mirror over and
over if he had sex with his wife
he actually confronts history teacher
Jake history teacher Jake can't even
bring himself to say that he didn't
sleep with actor Jake's wife an argument
ensues and a deal is made actor Jake
gets to take history teacher Jake's
girlfriend out on a date and then he
says he will disappear from his life
forever then they will be even
I believe he's intentionally starting a
war with his subconscious in an attempt
to eliminate the negative parts so he
can be with his wife in reality and
remain faithful and B even as one person
again history teacher decides to go to
actor Jake's wife now as this inward
battle occurs in his mind I believe the
real life Jake is the one who has now
gone back home to his wife as the
narcissistic unfaithful actor Jake is
taking out the girlfriend in his mind he
gets the doorman to let him into his
apartment
the doorman just so happens to be a man
who was in the sex club in the opening
scene he mentions to history teacher
Jake that he wants to go back to the sex
club again he mentions the lock to the
sex club has changed and that new keys
have been sent out history teacher Jake
seems unsure of what he's referring to
but goes along with the conversation
anyway history teacher Jake even walks
too far past his apartment door before
the doorman lets him in he appears to be
discovering things in his apartment for
the first time as he attempts to
resemble actor Jake
waiting in his bedroom seeing the
blueberries in the fridge this is when
history teacher Jake notices the
photograph it is identical to the torn
one he had in his possession earlier
except this one isn't torn and shows his
wife next to him when she arrives home
he nervously attempts to act like he
belongs during this we see actor Jake
attempting to get lucky with Melanie in
some hotel somewhere history teacher
Jake gets in bed with his wife nervous
about taking his clothes off she looks
at him longingly places his hand on her
pregnant belly then embraces him
asking if he had a good day at school
this takes him off guard and she tells
him to forget it going to sleep this
also supports my earlier assumption that
she knows he actually is a history
teacher which would explain why his
mother said he had a respectable job I
just feel like she was trying to help
him by going along with his psychosis
actor Jake and Melanie are having sex
and she gets extremely upset when she
notices the suntanned mark of a removed
wedding ring on his finger interestingly
history teacher Jake wakes up in bed
with his wife at this exact moment
suddenly Melanie wants nothing to do
with actor Jake and she storms away
actor Jake begins driving her home this
is an ER spliced with scenes of history
teacher Jake pacing back and forth and
eventually crying his wife comes to
comfort him their hands interlocking he
says through tears that he's sorry
during this actor Jake and Melanie began
arguing in the car his wife tells him
she wants him to stay and they begin to
make love as actor Jake and Melanie's
argument gets worse with her insulting
him by saying he's not a man
this makes actor Jake snap leading to a
terrible car crash we zoom in on the
window of the car revealing the cracked
glass resembling a spiderweb I feel that
in this moment Jake has successfully
used his subconscious war to eliminate
the negative self from himself his wife
wants him to stay which tells us that
they've been having a lot of problems
with their marriage and she wants him to
finally stay there and not be unfaithful
to her anymore the next morning we hear
a radio broadcast about an accident
but who I will now refer to simply as
Jake turns it off before any details are
mentioned his wife is in the shower and
he's trying on a suit when he finds the
package we've been shown this package
constantly throughout this film he
finally opens it finding a key he stares
at it with a look of temptation his wife
says his mother called he continues to
stare at the key
and asks his wife if she asks something
to do tonight because he has to go out
then would some have called the scariest
ending to a film they've ever seen
happens Helen Mellon now the majority of
audiences after initially screaming said
the same three words what the fuck it
took me quite some time before I finally
felt like I had a grasp of the story but
I can confidently say that I do so what
does all this mean well let's start with
the spiders spiders in the film
represent women at least in the way that
Jake views them he has a deep fear of
commitment
his wife is pregnant he's been
unfaithful in the past as it was made
clear when his wife asks if he's seeing
her again
and when his mother joked that he has
had enough trouble staying with just one
woman spiders in the real world catch
prey in their webs they entangle what
they are about to devour oftentimes when
mating the female spider actually kills
the male afterwards and sometimes even
before they begin to mate
the film is in a way saying that Jake's
character feels he's lost his freedom he
feels trapped within the web of his
marriage and the weighty responsibility
of having a child as well as remaining
faithful the constant reference to
dictatorship and being unwillingly ruled
has to do with Jake feeling that way
about his marriage and eventual family
in the opening of the film the
narcissistic unfaithful actor Jake gets
into the private sex club with his key
and watches a woman about to squash a
spider through his unfaithfulness he
longs to squash
his wife so to speak or their love at
least so he goes somewhere where that
doesn't exist where him and other men
can watch their sexual fantasies be
acted out due to his fear of committing
to his wife his dream of the nude woman
with a spider head supports that women
are the spiders as well and directly
after that a woman who looked very sexy
was dressed almost like a stripper past
him and he felt the sudden urge to go
and look at that woman and I feel like
that also supports the fact that he's
just very unfaithful and he wants to be
with a lot of women so how about that
giant spider roaming Toronto this scene
took place directly after he met with
his mother
I believe this spider represents his
mother here's something interesting this
is a monument known as the mother spider
guess where it's located
Ontario Canada where the film takes
place they look kind of similar dumping
so how about that final spider why did
his wife turn into a huge freaking
spider why did the spider react in fear
and why was his look one of almost
exceptive disappointment as if he has
just come to terms with what his life is
like when Jake opened the package taking
out the new key he realizes it's the key
to the sex club he gets a look of
temptation on his face and immediately
decides he has to go there telling his
wife he has to go out tonight suddenly
his wife is no longer answering him as
he calls to her and when she is revealed
to be a spider she backs up in fear of
getting squashed
Jake was able to successfully eliminate
the unfaithful narcissistic portion of
himself but at the first sign of
temptation he goes back to his
adulterous ways this is why she reacts
in fear
Jake is a spider killer he can't control
his urges and can't commit to a healthy
relationship or to the eventual family
he will have which he views has almost
like a dictatorship which is something
he is defiant to the attack of the
50-foot woman poster the song the
cheater playing in the store his torn
photo of him and his wife all support
that version of himself was haunted by
fear of women his unfaithfulness and his
attempts to ruin his marriage so why the
look of acceptive disappointment
remember earlier in the film when
history teacher Jake said this and it's
important to remember this that this is
a pattern that repeats itself
throughout history I believe Jake has
realized he's restarting the same
pattern he's repeating his same mistakes
almost instantly upon moving on from
them at the first sign of temptation
interestingly the film ends with him
missing a call from his mother and
begins with his receiving a voicemail
from her also remember this it was Hegel
who said that all the great greatest
world events happened twice and then
Karl Marx added the first time it was a
tragedy the second time the farce I
believe after having finally gotten over
his adultery and moving on from that
initial tragedy he now realizes this
repeating process is just going to be a
joke eventually a farce an unavoidable
negative of his life he's just going to
have to deal with think about it as
humans when we constantly deal with a
problem of some kind that doesn't go
away eventually we begin to accept it
and sometimes we even look for the
humor in it so lastly what is the film's
title mean who is the enemy he is the
enemy is himself his desires his fears
his inability to have a normal
relationship and these things will
eventually lead to the destruction of
his sanity his marriage and possibly
even his life I'm an optimist though so
I like to think that he works things out
often fictional movie world somewhere
enemy in my opinion is a masterpiece of
cinema a film that actually requires
serious thought I love it and I am so
glad to have finally come to what I feel
is an accurate understanding of it
thanks so much for watching guys and I
hope this has helped you understand the
film a little more as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes